c'est le grand jour
nous partons observer la migration des
rêves nivèse la migration des rêves ni
malgré ça consiste à rentrer à la maison
dont il autrement dit d'où l'on vient
owens a mis fin comme ça la star quelque
chose qu'on a au fond de soi un
sentiment de familiarité auquel on ne
peut pas résister ma mère mon père j'ai
une famille nous t'oublierons jamais
daury même si j'oublie ma famille m'a
manqué vous avez déjà ressenti ça oui
malok de malades mais là je fais
vraiment avec malaga vous pouvez m'aider
pardon je sais pas nager je trouve que
vous nagez très bien pu beaucoup mais
bon de croo pourri oui oui oui on met
tes copines
non c'était trop marrant mais je te
raconter une histoire et tu l'oubliés
complètement comme ça pouvait être
accordé autant de fois que je voulais
je cherche ma femme et que tu es folle
c'est trop dangereux
ces pauvres les élèves que je cligne des
yeux comment vous faites pour les garder
ouverts si longtemps
qu'est-ce qui se passe toi bonjour vous
pouvez m'aider c'est l'autre